in the meantime we've got a bit of
breaking news for you the pandemic the
war in Ukraine and climate change uh no
but we're not coming to that first we're
going to talk about the shell AGM which
is taking place right now uh there has
been some disruption at uh the show AGM
uh some climate change activists have
got into the meeting I think we can show
you a quick clip of uh sir Andrew
McKenzie the shell chairman uh dealing
with some of these people let's uh just
see if we can get that to you
don't you come back no more
[Music]
shut down shut down shut up shut up
shut up
that's uh sir Andrew McKenzie there the
uh shell chairman there uh disruption
most protesters worth actually pointing
out most uh shareholders in Shell are
peeved at just how much the company is
spending on the transition compared with
some of its uh American Rivals such as
Exxon and Chevron but we will have more
on that throughout the morning no doubt
here on Sky News